this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored
guitar confiscate rainbow hats and an
apparent Crackdown on Peaceful protests
to World Cup fans respect local laws or
risk their safety for gay rights
the UK Supreme Court prepares to rule on
a second referendum on Scottish
independence succession Legend Brian Cox
is here to debate secession
plus Isis bride shamima Baker launches
another bid to return to the UK
Britain's fight you say she knew exactly
what she was doing she a terrorist or a
victim
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening of London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
guitar is not a democracy migrant
workers there are treated badly gay
rights and women's rights are sorely
lacking by Western standards sexual
freedom is limited these are all facts
about Qatar but they're also facts about
Russia which hosted the last World Cup
and the facts about China which staged
the Winter Olympics just nine months ago
there are controversies almost
everywhere that any major sporting event
takes place unless the World Cup rotates
endlessly between Switzerland Sweden and
Finland there's always going to be a
problem well today's controversy is the
apparent Crackdown on a handful of fans
wearing rainbow hats and t-shirts in
support of gay rights Wales Ambassador
Laura McAllister said this
when we got through security and some of
the security guards said that we had to
take the hat off and when I asked them
why they said because it was a band
symbol and that we weren't allowed to
wear it in the stadium and I pointed out
that FIFA had made lots of comments
about supporting LGBT rights in his
tournament
it's a modest protest so frankly it's a
cause that I obviously support but what
were they expecting guitar warned as far
back as April that they confiscate
rainbow Flags partly other concerns that
local people might react angrily and
while FIFA says rainbow symbols are okay
inside stadiums they don't run the
country guitars opened its house to the
world and for the most part all fans
appear to be welcome but when you're in
someone else's house it's polite to
respect their rules even if you don't
agree with them now this so-called
Crackdown turns nasty I'll be the first
to call it out right now looks like
another version of the same argument
we've been having for months and years
about this Guitar World Cup it shouldn't
be left to fans to take the heat for
protests when the players themselves are
bottling it over the threat of a yellow
card Home Advantage is already having a
weird and wonderful impact though on the
first ever Middle Eastern World Cup
qatar's neighbors Saudi Arabia stunned
the world today by beating hot favorite
Argentina leaving a certain Lynn or
Messi oh looking less than chuffed
England could face Argentina in the next
round if they make it
so never mind respecting local Customs
we might be calling them for some
tactical advice on the side of thousands
of Saudi fans celebrating outside the
stadium is a reminder of what this is
supposed to be about they're not Muslims
or Middle Easterns or politicians
they're just actually football fans in
this scenario celebrating like the rest
of us would
well joining me now is political
activist asaga who disagrees with
everything I've just said good evening
to you good evening well I only uh
disclose some of it not all of it so
look here's my problem it's not that I
think that Qatar has an exemplary record
on human rights they don't my problem is
once you put the human rights Halo on
about where you stage Your World Cup I'm
not sure where you end up staging him
you can't have it in Africa you can't
have it in the Middle East you can't
have it in India you can't have it in
China I'm not sure you could have it in
America given their Draconian rules for
example about abortion which are very
offensive to many other countries
outside America in other words if you if
you start to be too saintly about it I'm
not sure you can end up having a World
Cup well I think if you take that logic
too far it means you end up drawing a
line absolutely nowhere and I think that
both of us would agree that you draw a
line somewhere and what we're disputing
is where you do it can I ask you a
really quick question sure back in the
1980s did you support the boycott of
apartheid South Africa yes yes and and
can you tell me why you supported that
worker uh because I felt that apartheid
South Africa was based on pure racism
and discrimination and you're going to
say to me now okay what's the difference
between that and the way guitar I'm not
saying what's the difference the thing
I'm saying is that at that time in the
1980s I mean I was barely twinkle in my
father's eye at that point yeah so my
mother tells me is that when you were
outside of Barclays encouraging Barclays
you know to divest from South Africa and
for people not to bank with Barclays or
when you were saying hang on the cricket
team or the rugby team or the football
team shouldn't do sporting tours in
South Africa South Africa people would
go well hang on there's so many other
countries with terrible human rights
records why are you doing this about the
Soviet Union why aren't you doing this
about China you can say why aren't you
doing this about this country for
practically any human rights issue you
care to name so for me there's a case
for people to boycott Qatar if that's
what they want to do do I also think if
that's what people wanted to do they
should have started organizing well I
agree I think if you feel that strongly
about it don't go to guitar and my
problem is once they've got the World
Cup which they rewarded 12 years ago
once everybody's there it's a football
tournament and I find the endless
politics now is just getting in the way
of what it should be support the Iranian
players refusing to sing the national
absolutely and using the press
conference to shine a light in the
conditions in Iraq that to me is moral
courage because they're doing it to
their own country they're making a stand
where there is genuine oppression of
women in that country right now that's
fine my problem is with England who
basically said with the football
association's backing we're going to
wear these up we're not going to boycott
it we're going to wear these armbands
supporting the LGBT community and then
they get threat with a yellow card and
they all run a mile you are not going to
get me to disagree with you on that one
because I thought it was frankly comical
pathetic right do you have got this
Iranian team who are putting their
careers and their freedom potentially
even their lives inside of the
protesters you've got the England team
saying okay well we're not going to back
down on our values and then somebody's
like oh no not a not a sporting punitive
measure I mean it's totally cowardly let
me ask you a question let me have to
disagree with you okay so we reached
some points of consensus but where would
you stage Your World Cup I mean the
World Cup's the biggest falling event in
the world where would you be happy to
see a stage so the thing I would say is
rather than doing this pick and choose
of countries is how are the decisions
right both me and one you can be happy
to be out both me and you I think could
probably agree that FIFA is such a
corrupt organization that there are
cartels out there going steady that's
not my question and so the problem is
the problem is I've asked you a simple
question him out throughout FIFA's
history because of that corruption
states which want to launder its image
by having this proximity in association
with sports have been able to do so and
it goes back way before Qatar it goes
way back it goes back to you know I
think it's been corrupt since it started
1978 World Cup so I think that you deal
with this by going well let's clean up
FIFA fine and then I agree we have some
standards imposes
don't be like a politician you ignore my
question no no this is one place in the
world you'd be happy to see the World
Cup posted Tottenham well you're talking
about I forgot that I mean there's even
more heinous than anything you've
discussed so far but seriously where
would you host it but for me this isn't
the point about countries
my point is could we actually
legitimately host it in England given
this moral criteria England took part in
the illegal invasion of Iraq in 2003
that's partly two decades of Isis
terrorism never mind anything else
caused huge Fury in the Middle East uh
we saw last year when we hosted the
European championships how disgusting
our fans many of them behaved at the
final at Wembley I was there they were
snorting goat boozing brawling breaking
in with no tickets spreading covid it
was a great weekend it was actually it
was disgusting to watch and dangerous so
my point is who are we to actually
lecture other countries about laws when
we who invaded countries illegally who
will lead to lecture people about for
example they say we can't drink beer
inside stadiums when they've watched
what happened at Wembley what you make
here is a good point which is that there
is no country who's whose hands are
clean and I think there's a more
important Point here which is that we
can't expect football to do things that
our government won't when you look at
amount of Qatari money which is sloshing
around London you're Sovereign wealth
fund buying up Harrods buying up
billions why shouldn't they in property
why shouldn't they be allowed to buy
Harris well I think what we're going to
end up with why shouldn't they own Paris
saint-german football team so I think
we're going to end up in the same
position as we did with Russian money
which is when we allow regimes that
we're dependent on for fossil fuels to
then use our finances we get 20 of our
gas from Qatar apparently I heard on
newsline I think it's six percent
according to government documents but so
a large chunk of gas comes from Qatar
would you turn that off in principle now
given the energy I would say I would say
so we don't have to buy fossil fuels
from Saudi Arabia or Qatar would you
would you turn off the gas tank I would
know I would say is we need to develop
an economy which isn't reliant on
imported fossil fuels and for decades we
haven't done that so this is my point
which is we have these huge expectations
of football to take stances that our
governments won't if we don't want Dirty
Money sloshing around the city of London
we need to tighten up our financial laws
we don't want to be dependent on these
countries we need to focus on
you have for five minutes now
steadfastly declined to answer my
question where would you host a World
Cup that you consider morally pure
enough to do it
I would say here's some criteria here's
some criteria you don't have a system of
exploited labor which means that
thousands of workers die in constructing
the infrastructure which is necessary we
don't know how many workers have died
you know we know the figure is 6500 is
deeply misleading because apparently
that's the total number of Migrant
workers you've died over a 10-year
period and many of them would have died
from natural causes in that time so we
don't actually know I'm not saying that
and it's maybe hundreds maybe thousands
I'm just saying we don't actually know
the reality the reason why we don't know
the reality is because either the Qatari
government hasn't bothered to count or
won't release the real thing let me come
back again
my question is this we've got to host
the World Cup somewhere do you agree
with that yeah so where do we host it so
this is again give me a country because
what you're trying to do is I'm trying
to ask yourself watching your interviews
but it's getting a bit old tax the thing
you do is you steer the interview down a
blind alley and you go answer this
question interviews where I make the
interviewer asked questions and you
either choose to answer them well you do
what you've done the last five minutes
which is answer can be a different
question what if I think is a stupid
question it couldn't be more pertinent
if you're a big problem
do you know that we should be hosting
the World Cup in Qatar where should we
be hosting but I said there's no country
with Clean Hands but what you can do is
with I'm not saying you have to have
clean hands to host a World Cup the
thing I'm saying we can have some
criteria
we can have some criteria that we will
just give me a country we can have
criteria that we all take any name
you'll take any name I gave you two 160
old countries in the world give me one
it gave you Tottenham the thing I'm
saying we can have some criteria that we
all agree on and what you can also do is
have FIFA using them
it's an improved condition this is the
problem it's all very well saying it's
all terrible guitar and he was all
terrible in Russia and his terrible the
Olympics were in China and his terrible
terrible terrible terrible but my
question is well where is it not
terrible enough to happen I think there
are countries with better human rights
records than Qatar give me a country
Chile has better human rights you would
have you would have the World Cup and
Chile that passed your moral smell test
really have you read about Chili's human
rights yes I have really yeah and I
think that Gabriel boric is quite a good
person wow you think Chile is actually a
good okay why don't you tell me
something about Chile right now which
means that that would be a terrible
country and is as bad as Qatar in terms
of gay rights in terms of workers rights
in terms of women's rights I named it I
played your silly game I played your
silly gameplay
you're doing what I would what you would
have done had I said Iceland you finally
you're going no no no
I'm not I'm not you didn't say Iceland
you would have been on safer territory
you've made it because I don't think
that football has named the country in
Chile which actually has a lot of Human
Rights problems you know that I know
that so come on talk to me what country
do you think should be is making I'm
perfectly happy with it being held in
Qatar so you think I actually think it's
outrageous that the Middle East has
never had a World Cup given how massive
football is in the middle so you think
it's okay for FIFA to a water World Cup
which you and I both know means billions
and billions of dollars of investment of
trade links well Qatar I've spent 200
billion so actually on this case
knowing full well that LGBT fans will be
less safe than heterosexuals there's
been no apparent persecution of any fans
knowing right if there is I'm I'm with
you no but at the moment they said that
everyone will be tolerated and so far it
appears to be the case knowing the
conditions for migrant work is there
because you know for many years during
there are many countries in the world
with bad conditions for migrant workers
we know that you had the um cafala
system legally it's not legally in place
anymore but the conditions haven't
improved so you're telling me you're
perfectly comfortable with all of that
and instead
I said I'm perfectly comfortable with
Qatar hosting the world cup
instead of FIFA because I think once you
put the moral Halo on about who can host
a World Cup as you've just discovered
you end up really struggling to find
somewhere which passes the test this is
why I think it's a stupid question it's
a very good question right no no because
actually you've got to have the World
Cup somewhere no of course you think
it's a good question because you like
asking silly questions
Saudi Arabia one of the minnows of world
football 50 odd in the world in football
take down the favorites to win the
competition led by Lionel Messi one of
the greatest sporting upsets in history
and just today I just would love to
celebrate that look I love football
tournaments not just because I get to
see Ronaldo running around in Sugar love
football and support Tottenham listen
two things the two things do not go
ahead this is going to be an even worse
debate than the ones I'm going to end
the debate now it's been a good debate
it's an interesting debate and I'm not
sure we've reached much Clarity but
thank you for coming ask about a
question and we might you spot the wrong
team that's the problem I'll welcome my
questions coming next tonight succession
star Brian Thompson why Scotland he said
to never be more ready for Independence
foreign
[Music]
UK Supreme Court we'll rule tomorrow on
whether Scotland can hold a new
Independence referendum without the UK
government's consent legendary actor
Brian Cox is back in the hot seat here
and has been one of the first system
most famous advocates for breaking up
the Union right good evening how are you
I'm good let me see before we get into
actually ironically I don't want to
break up the union but I've got another
idea for the union United Federation
would explain independent countries
working in in I mean Wales Ireland
Scotland and England because I think
England gets a lot of the tap into the
bath I'm by Nature an anglophile that's
where I I studied here in London so I'm
very disposed to that what I just
believe in is the independent states uh
but we come together as a United
Federation is that not what the UK is
not supposed to be but it's not because
too many decisions are made on behalf of
like this major decision that's been
made in Wales about this Chinese thing
you know whether it's supposed to be
contentious there's a dangerous element
they say but the Welsh are getting no
say in the matter which I think is
really wrong so I'm all for I don't want
to break up the the union because it's
you know we are the British Isles but I
want my country not just my country I
want Wales Scotland and England to be
independent most interesting we had a
lot of bait obviously but I wanted to
leave the European Union and a recent
survey this week in yougov says now only
32 percent of britons now think it was
the right thing to do to leave 56 think
it was wrong that's a massive shift
absolutely but then that was so corrupt
I mean so rotten the whole thing and we
Scotland voted 62 percent to stay yes I
know but does that not give you pause
for thought about leaving no Collective
entity which brings with it at least
you know strengthen numbers but the
north of England and who have been
systematically ignored time and time
again have have are getting you know
their well cheesed off about the fact
that they don't have enough say in their
life you know and you think of the great
things that Andy Burnham's doing in
Manchester for example and I'm more I'm
all for I'm all for uh the England
expressing themselves in the same way
that Scotland does and that we come
together in a proper Federation where we
contribute we don't do that now because
the rules are all set down here and the
problem I think if I was Scottish right
now given the utter Fiasco of the way
this government has behaved in the last
six months alone from Boris
we went on question time and we did
equally rage but it has been completely
shameful that we've had these three
prime ministers now Boris Johnson total
shambles with all the nonsense he got up
to Liz trust unbelievably for that short
44 days even worse tanking the economy
tanking the bound tanking everything and
now we're picking up the pieces and now
Richard cynic has to try and repair all
the damage but if I'm Scottish looking
at all this I'm thinking look at these
London politicians behaving like
Reckless Casino owners with our money
and we have no real say over what these
people are doing that's my point you've
just made my point well I agree but I
see that's where I have sympathy no and
that's that's the whole point but the
problem is that we that systematically
again and again and again we'll have
those guys and those gals making those
decisions you know I don't know what's
going to happen in the next election I
suppose that the probably labor will get
in but we need Vision we need real
vision and those creatures were just who
do you see who do you see out there that
you think is actually an impressive
politician who might have a vision well
I believe in nickel sturgeon yeah I do
yes I do I think the and they've had a
lot of problems up there right don't get
me wrong they've had a lot of problems
but I do trust Nicola I think she's the
genuine article I mean I've got to say
in her credit she's always faced the
music you know I've done many interviews
with her often quite hostile she always
comes back she doesn't duck interviews
like Boris did for so many years
um she's divisive but she certainly has
what I would call leadership skills
exactly and she's a great leader and I
think she will lead us and but as I say
appears and I really mean this and
people say oh you go on about
independent Scotland I'm interested in
in the the countries in this country and
this Kingdom so-called United Kingdom
being separate being individual being
completely autonomous but they also are
part of a federation that's exactly
that's exactly what I think in the
Federation I mean who would have any
power in that would it be equal power no
it would be equal power and there'd be
there would be what would the Federation
decide that the independent autonomous
countries couldn't decide for themselves
well they well most of the stuff
domestically they could decide for
themselves but when it comes to the
interchange with each each country then
they would have to come to some kind of
agreement it it won't be easy but it
never is what do you do for example
about currency because you wouldn't it
would take you years to go back into the
EU which is still I think what more
Scots would prefer to do but it would
take years to facilitate well I'm Bank
of England have said if you leave the UK
you can't have the pound so what do you
do if it's practical level what do you
do well it's a pleasure thing that one
has to Encompass you know you're gonna
have to deal with it one way or the
other but then again we didn't go Euro
uh we kept a pound uh during this whole
situation so we we never made that we
never made that transition I don't know
what would happen in terms of but then
if we had a United Federation we would
come to some decision on that very
subject that's what about what about the
Border we've had this nightmare from
brexit of Northern Ireland and what to
do with it there's this belief that if
Scotland really wants Independence
you've got to rebuild Hadrian's Wall are
you going to be standing there with your
marauding armor no fending off the
invading
but no I think that but what do you do
practice again practical level what do
you do about a border if you are a
genuine independent how do you do with a
border between Belgium and France how do
you deal with the Belgium between France
and Spain would you have a physical
border you would just shut the border it
would be there you know it would be at
Hadrian's Wall which was a natural
border
do you think what when you go up to
Scotland what's the mood about
would you say because the polls at the
moment do not see a majority in any of
the polls for wanting to have an
independent Scotland or indeed another
referendum so why why do you believe
you're nearer to it now than you were
well I just think because um and
certainly in Scotland's uh you know I
mean it changes daily you know because
there's always and the Scots are
notorious they're contentious they can
be very contentious to Scott I know
because I am one uh I was watching Peter
Capaldi the other night and he said the
great gift of my family was family and
sarcasm
then I think that's very true sorry what
was your question again I know my
question what is it about the mood in
Scotland do you think which makes you
think the polls are wrong people do want
to have I I think a genuine independent
country because we've seen what's
happened recently which has been pretty
horrific with Johnson uh you know trusts
very briefly it was a good did somebody
else comment well it's now Richie soon
act you know so and that party has just
gone from worst to worst to worse to
worse to worse so we don't want any
truck with that we we're constant we're
like we're like Blanche Dubois we're
always depending on the kindness of
strangers and in a way we just need to
be able to form and also it's to do with
culturally who we are you know we're
culturally different we're not the same
and you know when I grew up in Scotland
it was North Britain and that the great
thing about Scotland and the and this
the SNP party was regarded as a joke but
they have moved towards you see why I
joined why I became part of a you know
Scottish I don't like the word
nationalist I've never liked the word
natural but I believe in Scottish
independence nationalism is too
contentious a word for me but when Blair
made the whole Fiasco which we're still
suffering from in the Middle East and he
got into bed with you know uh Cheney and
Rumsfeld and the puppet as he was really
Bush and and Halliburton and oil I just
thought it's so obvious that this is a
corrupt thing that's happening and we
should not be part of that yeah now in
Scotland we would say no we're not going
to do that but of course we have no
power we have no power to make any
opinion and I was a labor man for a long
time and I'm still a socialist in
principle but you know at the end of the
day uh that's why I think we have to
come back to ourselves it's interesting
I mean he brought up Iraq I was editor
of Delhi mirror we opposed the Iraq War
we lost the campaign sadly but when you
look at this furorian Qatar what do you
make of it because my is that I'm not
sure we are morally pure enough here to
really be talking to the guitarist about
how their laws are or anything else well
I think to a certain extent you're right
but I also think that
uh I think what's happening you know we
let's look at Iran and let's look at
what's happening in Iran where there's a
there's a sort of possible female
Revolution right and it's being led by
women right see I do think the
patriarchy is over and I think the we
need to give these women the the rights
that they deserve and we haven't done it
and I think that goes from most of the
Middle Eastern Nations when that's also
to do with religion we don't go into
that but as certainly these women need
to be freed up in a way that they're not
being freed up how would Logan Roy react
to the question he would do something
else
but I also think going back to the
question of Cutler yeah uh there that
should have been dealt with a long time
ago set blatter has already admitted it
was a corrupt thing yeah so we know it
was corrupt but they should have dealt
with it a long time ago not now this is
not the point when I had that debate
before I spoke to you with our soccer I
mean when you actually do try and work
out where is morally pure enough to have
a World Cup Iceland right I mean you're
pretty much a nice and every year right
yeah and even there if we dug deep
enough with all the world's journalists
you probably find all sorts of problems
there well my point my point being that
It's Tricky right you can't just
obviously have it nice and every year no
you could well it's not every year it's
every four years but why should the
Middle East have a World Cup no I think
they should have a World Cup but there's
a lot of stuff that's gone on I mean the
Saudis beat Argentina incredible but
then think of what the Saudis did to
that journalist in Turkey of course
exactly so then you know is there any
more morally repugnant than us illegally
invading Iraq well we haven't done that
kind of thing we haven't actually or we
legally invaded a sovereign country
that's what we did we did it and I'm not
sure there's a moral difference to be
honest yeah but but just because there
wasn't a moral difference doesn't mean
to say you have to not abandon that
issue and just say perhaps there needs
to be a bit of morality in dealing with
things let's take a short break I want
to come back you're a Manchester United
fan I am and you saw the Ronaldo
interview I did great interview when it
gets your reaction so Ronaldo off the
brain foreign
[Music]
Cox is still with me Brian you're a man
united fan the biggest star arguably
United has ever had Cristiano Ronaldo
went public in this big interview with
me let's just have a reminder of some of
the things you said
I'm trying to force you out yes not only
the coach but the other two or three
guys they are around
the club at the senior executive level
yes that I felt betrayed I don't know
what's going on but since
since the Sarah likes Ferguson left I
saw not evolution in the club the
progress was Zero legalizes they don't
they don't care about about the club the
empathy with the coach is not good I'm
I'm honest you don't have a good
relationship
I'm not mean good relationship you think
he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve you must be worried
sick I mean you I was very worried I was
very baby son and now your baby
daughter's in hospital exactly kind of
that didn't believe
that's something going wrong which is
this make me feel bad really yes I am
yes I didn't believe you they believe
you but in the same way they are their
peace ever gonna change
the health of my family
for a football never
Cristiano Ronaldo that entities have
been viewed 15 million times on our
YouTube channel 45 million more views of
the clips on social media make it one of
the biggest most watched interviews in
history certainly for sport what did you
make of it bro I mean Cristiano Ronaldo
United Legend torching really the club
um what do you think well I think it's
I can see where he's coming from
but he also has to understand that it is
not about Ferguson anymore it's not that
United and I could see that there was
probably a great sentimental movement to
go back to the club where he really
began where all began and Alex well you
know there's nobody there's nobody like
Alex Ferguson and Alex persuaded him and
I was expected to come back yeah well
thinking well Alan's well naturally
because Alex loves the club and he's
trying to keep the club but the club has
gone through many so many changes in the
last few years now playing for Juventus
and playing for Real Madrid and their
clubs have been in an incredible they
haven't stopped they're just the top of
the league Manchester United has not
been playing well over the last few
years but it's beginning to get its
it's mojo back and I think it's
unfortunate that this has happened is he
entitled to speak out well of course
he's entitled to speak up but but also
you want us to examine exactly where
he's coming from and I think he's coming
from a place where he's saying you know
I I wanted to go back to a beginning I
wanted to go back to that Glory Days
that where when I was a young boy and I
understand he said his heart ruled his
head to it he's not brought his head to
a degree and in a sense
that's going to be difficult and a
manager who's trying to create a new
club and there's going to be a clash and
I think it's it's it's quite tragic
actually and it's tragic for him but
it's also tragic for the club yeah you
know and I think the club has to be
given a break on this I mean I I do
think it's hard it's clearly hard
because his expectation must have been
huge and especially if Alex persuaded
him to go by that must have been a huge
thing but he's been disappointed and you
can't take away his disappointment
because it is not the same club that he
was at all those years ago have you ever
had a situation in your career when
you've been tempted to walk out have you
walked out a a show or play a TV show
anything like that no no I just I I'm
clever enough to avoid going into those
situations have you seen people do it
yeah I've seen people walk away you know
and uh you know and I've understood why
they do it and there's it's usually
complex reasons when I did it actually
well yeah but I did it because actually
when I listened to Ronaldo I sort of
thought yeah it was he actually comes
down to respect I think it doesn't
matter what the job is if you actually
feel disrespected in your workplace
that's right and you feel you're being
forced down an Alleyway you don't want
to go down I actually think there's a
certain marriage just saying actually
it's not for me thanks yeah and I think
that's maybe I mean that this I mean I'm
glad the interviews had the the
coverage that it's had in terms of I
mean amazing 50 million is quite
incredible but at the same time I'm
going
um it's rather sad that that's the view
you're going to get because you know I
think and certainly with these kids and
with his family and you know going back
to Manchester is a difficult thing I
think losing the baby in the tragedy
with the twins and one died and one
lived that's kind of really not really
any human being and I think he wanted a
bit more of an arm wrap yeah and he
didn't get it yeah and and that's and
she may just really be as simple as that
yeah
um talking of arm wraps the
extraordinary series you've got on
channel five how the other half live
both rich but particularly pertinently I
thought the poor and you went down for
this series you went to Food Banks I
want to show a little clip first and ask
you about this well actually no I come
here every Friday so that I can feed my
son over the weekend we're working
part-time and we still can't afford it
yeah my electricity has gone up from
five to four pounds a month to 170 a
month that's astronomical it really is
Hardcore and it really is we prioritize
our children and go without I think
that's yeah but all adults and parents
are doing just now really isn't it it's
shocking how Dundee has gone pretty much
full circle getting back to the poverty
I saw as a kid it's extremely painful
this stuff
you know it's painful for anybody if
you've got any sensibility at all this
stuff is painful
so they won't you just corrected me
there they weren't food banks they're
called Community
well the difference is what people feel
about food banks is loss of dignity yeah
and the one thing that human beings have
even when they don't have any money is
some kind of dignity some kind of
feeling of who well-being of who they
are and what the community ladder does
is it charges the minimal but it means
you're paying for something so there's a
transaction you're being given it you're
not being given it's not begging because
a lot of being in food banks feels like
begging and the fact that they're being
constantly legitimized is really irksome
to me but this community allowed are run
by these two amazing women who actually
run a play group and it was out of a
play group they decided to go on to this
and people like little Morrisons they
give stuff which is coming up to Itself
by date that then they can tap on and
the thing that you don't see in the
program which is one of my angers with
my editor in that anyway that's neither
here nor there but the thing you don't
see is a guy who came in
at the community ladder it was called
Peter Lee he came in and uh he was a
frail man the stick and he had a sign on
his arm
and I said so you do this for your
family and he said no no I do it for
people who can't get here it was 15
people he did it for wasn't it yeah
that's right he said I do it for them
and he said and I said really he said
yeah I said that's amazing he said I do
sort of five a week I do different
groups you know people who can't older
people who can't get down from the high
rises I said that's that's extraordinary
and I said so what's the sign he said
I'm blind
I I just
almost fell off my chair I just thought
you got quite tearful actually I did I
did because I just thought the heroism
with this guy you know this guy's a real
hero and I just thought wow you know
this man has really given something of
his life to this to this horrible
situation and trying to make it better
for us so many people in this country in
the whole of the UK are now literally on
the poverty yeah and it's probably going
to get worse before we get 11 inflation
this energy crisis the war in Ukraine
all these things conspiring to fall out
from the pandemic you saw at the sharp
pain I mean you went back to you to your
hometown and you were horrified by what
you found what do we do about this
it's a big question it's a big issue
I think
well I think Independence would help
certainly in Scotland's case but I also
think elsewhere would help I mean we'd
only help if the economy yeah was
revised that's right and many economists
think that Scottish independence would
be bad for the scholarship yeah well I I
would argue with that but I haven't got
the time to do that here but no I mean I
just I I feel that it we're going from
bad to worse but we but we've
again and again and again we have
neglected our own and it's Suddenly at a
bad time now when everything is against
us the cost of living crisis what have
you the the war the in the the the
pandemic what the pandemic has done but
even so
their lives haven't changed the budget
didn't help them those people and it
never does it never does it never looks
to the poorest we don't concern
ourselves with that they're an
embarrassment let's put them over there
but now and why I wanted to do this
program was to bring it to the floor and
say these people matter and we have to
do something about it we have to have
some attitude that we haven't got that
we've kind of elbowed so long for too
long actually and that's what I feel
it's powerful stuff and I commend people
to watch it how the other half live on
channel five can't let you go without
asking you about succession one of my
favorite shows ever in the history of
television
you've got a new series coming coming in
the new year can you tell me anything or
do you have to shoot me
peers I don't have a gun
but if I did you'd have to be shocked is
Logan Roy in series six well there's
some series six we're only series four I
know that's a trick question
you know what let's see what happens I
mean in other words does he survive this
series well it's four you're doing now
so it's been like yeah he'll survive
this year yeah there'll be no problem
there's no death to be after no no no no
none of that that's all that's all
speculation and nonsense no I mean
there's a lot to be dealt with in terms
of who's going to take over and there's
a lot to be dealt with in terms of the
writers and where they can go with it
see the great thing about Jesse
Armstrong is he doesn't stay too long at
the fair right
because each season has topped the last
season so we have to keep talking it
reminds me of Aaron Sulkin on The West
Wing where the first four seasons were
fantastic then he left and the writing
collapsed and the whole thing and that's
what we don't want to happen yeah would
you rather end on a high I would rather
end on a high yeah you know and leave
them wanting more lot less yes and uh
well you know there's a I mean I'm no
names no pactro but there's a show
called billions you know and uh Damien
Lewis left and they're still going on
with it yeah I know but it's it's
overeating the souffle that's what I
would call a wee bit how many times a
day do you get told to tell people to f
off all the time like a dozen times I
was at the Scottish Baptist last night
and it was I couldn't get away from
people and of course as I said before
it's the it's the
the best thing to tell people yes
because when you're fed up with them you
go oh yeah
you can say it won't bleep you oh
anymore just
and finally as a Scot who do you most
want to win the World Cup England or
Wales
um or somebody else
uh uh I have to reserve judgment on that
oh come on no no I'm not I can't do that
do you want England to beat say you know
I think I think I I'd like to see
England do well because I think he's
done a great job yeah I think he's
really done a great job and there's some
great players we've got a few good
Arsenal players in there yeah
what a player tremendous I was worried
about him because he got uh a couple of
games ago they they took his legs from
him he's made a tough stuff uh bro
brilliant to see you well coming next
we'll debate uh this theory that Harry
and Megan are not a pair of Shameless
little grifters who ditched Britain and
Royal duty but are in fact Heroes worthy
of an award from the Robert F Kennedy
Foundation
[Music]
welcome back to Pierce Morgan sensors
official uh Harry and Megan are heroes
we've got it all wrong they've been
given a human rights award for their
heroic stand against structural racism
in the British Monarchy the award is
called the Ripple of Hope awarded by the
Robert F Kennedy human rights
organization that's the same Bobby
Kennedy who was a genuine hero well I'm
joined Now by talk TV contributor Paula
Ron Adrian talk to your presenter
Richard Tice please commentator Jenny
Clement all right Jenny
Heroes apparently
um for trashing their families on
National Television repeatedly and
they're about to do it again in the
documentary series about it again in
Harry's book They're trashing their
families with unsubstantiated smears
about being cruel and racist and so on
the heroes and they're literally been
put on the same pedestal at this Robert
F Kennedy Foundation Awards night in
December with Vladimir zielinski the
president of Ukraine saving his people
almost single-handedly in terms of his
morale boosting from from the hordes
from Russia sorry have I got nuts is
this is this happening I think this is a
pretty strange award I looked it up on
my way it's even broken you the MC is
Alec Baldwin who's facing potential
criminals three shots somebody exactly
so I'd say this is a pretty strange
event it's a pretty strange award it's
got a fancy name on it I think what this
shows is two things one how Awards don't
really mean very much because they can
be quite strange and you never know
who's on the panel judging you the other
thing is I think you know they're seen
differently in America to how they're
seen here
um I know I've been in America there's a
lot more sympathy for Megan than there
is actually it's a lot less than there
used to be even though not less than
they used to be I think the liberal
Elite like to buy them with these Awards
because they get huge attention I mean
Richard isn't this really the worst
aspect of celebrity which is they've
made themselves famous with all the
trashing they've been doing and as a
result the liberal Elite in America want
to be associated with them because
they'll get huge publicity for their
events but it's worse than that because
actually we now know and you identified
at early doors that the accusations that
she leveled against the royal family
were folks yes and so they've been given
an award an award for something that is
basically false and therefore in my view
the award itself is fraudulent I
completely agree and the worst thing
Paula about this Robert Kennedy was a
genuine hero I mean he fought so hard
for civil rights against poverty against
the Vietnam War he worked alongside Dr
Martin Luther King until they both got
assassinated this is real heroism that
he was up to for this Foundation this is
one of his dog Waters who runs it Kerry
Kennedy I think is completely Shameless
and shameful can I start by saying that
yes you're right you have lost your mind
this is about an institution a very
renowned institution that has decided to
give an award to two people who they
think are deserving they have their own
policies and procedures and practices in
place which they have considered and
tested and decided that Harry Megan
deserve this award
manure they the whole thing who says
they don't deserve the award you say
they don't deserve the Wardrobe
racism in the royal family exists really
well that exists and where we say that
it's not been proven yet of course we
know how difficult it is to deal with
the issue of racism we know how much
harder it is to deal with the fact that
we're talking about an institution she
said that their son had not been made a
prince because of his skin color
completely untrue absolute lie she also
said that several times a member of the
royal family expressed concern about the
skin color of their child and then Harry
said it happened once two years
previously they couldn't even get the
story right and they've never named who
that person is I've even been told by
one person it wasn't even a member of
the royal family yeah the whole family
gets smeared as a bunch of callous
racists I don't I don't think that's
actually right I think what happened is
that they have raised the issue of
racism and they have made the British
public they've made the institution that
is the royal family confront the issue
of racism
they accuse the royal family of being a
bunch of callers racists and there's no
way
where is the evidence of the racism
and they are saying to you we have
suffered this what's their truth there's
either the truth or something is their
truth that's another ridiculous Phrase
My Truth was my truth your truth is
that you are getting so angry about this
this is how is how we feel we as I'm
talking about members members of the
community who've suffered racism it's so
hard to express is that lived experience
it's so hard to express that truth
because
what we're told is is that we're being
fraudulent in when we're expressing that
so why aren't you as angry as I am about
these two people who who've issued
untrue statements about racism that have
not been proven and have now got some
people in America thinking the royal
family is a bunch of racist you can't
have an untruth statement that's not
been proven it's their truth and I
appreciate it and I appreciate there's
been no tribunal is that me saying right
it's like me saying that me saying I I
think you are a deeply unpleasant piece
of work right I think you're a
well-known cocaine abuser you're not as
far as I'm aware right
um but it's my truth I believe that yes
so because I believe it that's it you
just now unfortunately be saddled with
the reputation of being a drug abuser no
what do you say to me I would challenge
that it's my truth I would challenge
don't ever challenge
I lived experiences I think you are I
would challenge that my living
experience
Harry and Megan have done it every
opportunity that they've got they
challenged it and they challenged it
through the courts and they were
successful challenge so in terms
of stories they've not changed anything
about the racism so when they've had an
opportunity as I've said to challenge
um accusations that have been levered at
them in the Press they've taken that
they've challenged it so where's your
challenge my challenge is I think
they're telling a fact it's a shout
abuse and to call them people no no it's
not I think they are frauds let's say we
agree to disagree it's not proven let's
say that actually it might have happened
it might not the last thing you do for
some award ceremony for such an esteemed
Foundation is this is to make your
decision when it hasn't been improved
they should have waited and waited and
in the horrific instance that it was
proven that's a whole different board
let's see the evidence um let's move on
to shameema begum so I've got quite a
strong view about this I think she knew
exactly what she was doing and she went
out she had three kids with an Isis
terrorist who was chopping people's
heads off no sympathy you made your bed
with a terrorist you're lying it that's
it I just completely just agree with you
I think this is open and shut case of
trafficking she's 15 years old we accept
that the girls in Rotherham and Rochdale
when they were 15 years old didn't know
what was going on didn't know what was
happening to them you cannot make
decisions When You're 15 years old where
you understand the enormous lifelong
consequences when I was 15 years old I
was very smart I was doing very well at
school I'm sure that if somebody said to
me you know I could run away with rock
band I probably would have done that as
well I think there's two issues here it
seems to me this is a very clever lawyer
who's looking at what's the single way
of of getting uh begum back into the
country but here's the thing actually we
have to set an example and we have to
say to people this is a national
security threat and if you go overseas
it to join terrorist groups you are not
going to be welcome or able I wouldn't
trust as far as I could throw why should
I trust it you have to set an example he
was a 15 year old child
to what Jenny has said they weren't
actually believed at first it took years
and years
she
so her reality is very different from
them you're a very forgiving person you
really see the best in all these people
Isis Terror brides
no we have to set an example not of
children you're not coming back
yes or no no you would yes you would of
course
come here you run in the country please
thank you to my pack for tonight that's
it for me whatever up to keep it
uncensored
[Music]